مساء الخير تجدد الاهتمام مره اخرى
بطموحات السعوديه النوويه بعدما اصدر
الكونغرس الامريكي تقريرا مهما جدا يتهم
الرئيس الامريكي
بمحاوله تسريب توقيع تكنولوجيا نوويه
امريكيه للرياض سرا والمخالفه للقوانين
الامريكيه
وبدا الكونغرس بالفعل تشكيل لجنه في
تسعطاشر فبراير الجاري للتحقيق في كامل
الواقع اللي استندت فيها تقرير اللجنه على
تسريبات من مسؤولين داخل اداره الرئيس
القصه كلها بتطرح برمتها ممنوعه من
الاسئله المهمه
السعوديه
وليه الاداره الامريكيه ممكن تساعد الدوله
زي السعوديه سره لشراء تكنولوجيه نوويه
ايه اللي بدا على الكونغرس ربما تكون افضل
بدايه نفهم القصه كلها انه احنا نفهم
القصه من الجانب السعودي الطموحات
السعوديه للحصول على تكنولوجيه نوويه
سلميه وعسكريه ليست سرا وفي الفين واحد
عشر اعلنت السعوديه عن خطه طموحه لبناء
سطاشر مفاعل نووي كبير على مدار خمسه
وعشرين سنه وكان الهدف المعلن انه اقتصادي
بحث لانه السعوديه وهي يعني اكبر او ثاني
اكبر منتج للبترول بعد الولايات المتحده
مؤخرا بانتاج يصل الى عشره مليون برميل
نفط يوميا بتستهلك
او عشره هذه الكميه للاستهلاك المحلي لسد
احتياجات السوق المحلي من تكيفات ومصانع
وخلافه وده استخدامها الرشيد
لانه مصادر الطاقه الاخرى حتى تبقى ارخص
مقارنه بالبترول بمعنى انه البترول اذا
كان فيه برميل بترول ثمن ولا يكون مائه
دولار اذا تم تحويله الى صناعات يعني الى
كما كانت يتضاعف سعر من مائه دولار الى
1200 دولار لنفس البرميل واذا كانت
الصناعات معقده ومركبه متقدمه يعني قد يصل
سعرها تريد للبرميل الواحد بعد تصنيعه
اثنا عشر الف دولار وبالتالي السعوديه في
باقي دول العالم تريد ان هي تحرر هذه
الطاقه الذهب الاسود الى قيمه مضافه اغلى
واثمن بكثير من مجرد توليد الكهرباء
البديل انهى تجد طاقه الرياح
بطاقه شخصيه لكن ايضا طاقه نوويه واذا
كانت عندي موجود عند السعوديه وعند
الامارات وعندها مصر في نفس الفتره عند
الدول الاخرى الدول اللي بدات بالفعل محطه
التابعه المحطه النوويه في الامارات بدايه
من الفين وتسعه ثم مجموعه ال اه المحطات
الاعلانات السعوديه على المستوى السلمي
على المستوى العسكري السعوديه لم تخفي
ابدا في اطار عدائها الدائم مع ال ايران
على لسان الى الملك سلمان وعلى لسان ولي
عهد الامير محمد انه السعوديه لم تقف
مكتوفه الايدي اذا ال ايران اه بدات في
تصنيع سلاح نووي سوف اغادر ايضا الى تصنيع
سلاح نووي طبعا عشان هي تعمل سلاح سلمي او
تعمل المائه او عسكريه لا بد الناهيه ما
عندهاش التكنولوجي لازم هي تقترب قوات
حاولت تباحث مع الدول اللي تملك هذه
التكنولوجيا
الدوله ب تملك هذه التكنولوجيا ثلاثين
دوله في العالم منها ثمانيه اعلان اللي هم
عندهم اه القدرات النوويه
وفي دوله تسعى عندهم قدره لكنها لا تعلم
اللي هي اسرائيل كل الدول دي او الدول
المهم فيها
اهتمام بانه هي تلبي الطلب السعودي
والسعوديين توصلوا مع عدد كبير منهم اذا
كان الروس او ال اه الصينيين
لكن ايضا كان الامريكان على راس الدول
اللي تواصلت معها الامريكان الكلام على
سطاشر مفاعل يعني اكثر من بلد واكثر من
شركه واكثر من سوء
لكن الحقيقه انه المفاوضات السعوديين على
مدار عده سنوات مع الامريكان لم تصل الى
نتيجه ل انها اصطدمت
برفض الامريكان الى اعتبار او الى شرط
اساسي مصر عليه الشرط الاساسي انه على
السعوديين كل الدول اللي ساعد الاستفاده
من التكنولوجيا الامريكيه ان يقبلوا بما
يسميه الامريكان اكورد ستاندر كردستان
الشرط الذهبي
المصري التخلي عن حق هذه الدوله في تخصيب
اليورانيوم رغم ان هذا التخصيب يكفله
القانون الدولي ولا يمنعه دوله في
الامارات وافقت انا مش عاوزه اننا يكون
عندي الحق في تخصيب اليورانيوم مش مشكله
لان انا عندي الهدف سلمي المائه في المائه
السعوديين رفضوا رفضا تاما التوقيع على اي
التزام مع الامريكان ولا مع اي جهه اخرى ب
اه
بالتنازل عن حقها في اكتساب القدره على
تخصيب اليورانيوم مشكله القدره على تخصيب
اليورانيوم لما ارفضه
يعطي اشاره لهذه الدوله وللمجتمع الدولي
انني عندي طموح وعندي استعداد الى
الانتقال بهذه القدره انا لما املك القدره
على تخصيب اليورانيوم بمستويات الدنيا
الاغراض السلميه ما دام توفرت لي القدره
يمكن الانتقال من الاستخدام السلمي الى
الاستخدام العسكري في مرحله لاحقه وهذا ما
يتحفظ عليها الامريكان ويرفض القانون
الامريكي السعوديين وواضح ان هم اذا كان
المفاوضات المعلنه لكن الواضح انه كان
وراء الكواليس المساله كانت ماشيه في
اتجاه ثاني خالص الواضح ان السعوديين
واللوبي السعودي في الولايات المتحده كان
يراهن على القادمه الجديد الى البيت
الابيض اللي هو دونالد
والمفاوضات بدات معهم البيع تكنولوجيا
نوويه للسعوديه منذ ان كان مرشحا يعني لسه
في اثناء الحمله الانتخابيه
عاده لما بنحاول
نحل القرار الدوله او توجه دوله دائما
بنركز على مصالح الدوله يعني الولايات
المتحده تستفيد
البريطانيه هذا استفيد ايه لكن فيه عنصر
التالي مهم جدا لفهم القرارات وهي النخبه
الحاكمه تستفيد ايه الولايات المتحده
جازما تستفيد كثير لكن الله يستفيد عدد
كبير من رجال الاعمال والمؤسسات اللي ضغطت
على القادم الجديد واللي كان مرحب هذا
الضغط الاسباب انتخابيه بحث نفهم القصه
الحمله الانتخابيه
قطع انتخابيا لاعاده الحياه الى الصناعه
الطاقه النوويه اللي موجوده في الولايات
المتحده والتي تعاني كسادا منذ نحو ثلاثين
عام بالسبب
تشبع السوق الداخلي من ناحيه وكمان القيود
المتشدده من وجهه نظرهم من السلطات
الامريكيه اتجاه تصدير التكنولوجيا
النوويه وفرض شروط كثيره جدا مقارنه بشروط
الاقل بالمنافسه الاخرين روس وصينيين ومن
كوريا الجنوبيه النتيجه ان هذه الشركات
اللي كانت عندها الرياده اصبحت يعني اه
بتعاني من كاس اه الشركات بمجرد ما اعلنه
السعوديه عن رغبتها في التوسع في الطاقه
النوويه وجدت املا في هذا السوق وزي
مواصفه واحد الرؤساء الشركات بانه الاعلان
السعودي يمثل صفقه العقد يعني جديد كيت
عشر سنوات
ولكن لصناعه الطاقه النوويه في الولايات
المتحده لانه سته اشهر دول
تكلفته حوالي مائه مليار دولار
جدا يعني ادى صفقه السلاح كل ها اللي
بيتابع الرئيس الامريكي دونالد
الشركات ال ال ال التي تقدم هذه
التكنولوجيا عملت ل وبينك يعني تجمعت مع
بعضها عرض في الشركه الدكتور جنرال
الكتريك
ومجموعه اخرى من الشركات او شركه اخرى
كانت اكثرهم نشاط الاسماء
في
الشركه دي تحديدا مع باقي الشركات كما
تصرف في التقرير اشتروا اثنين من المقربين
جدا من اصدقاء دولتان مايكل فلان اللي كان
مستشارا للامن القومي واللي كانت احد دعم
حملته الانتخابيه
ثم اصبح مستشارا للامن القومي قبل ان يضطر
للاستقاله على خلفيه اتهامه بال
بال اتصال بال روس اثناء الحمله
الانتخابيه
مايكل فليب ومع رجلا عمل اخر من اصدقاء
بيعرفوا من تلك خمسه وثمانين وبيعرف
اللي هو يسيبوا اللي هو اه اه اه اللي
بيقود عمليه السلام في الشرق الاوسط
وهذا الشخص هو اللي ساعد في اقاله اه اسره
كاشمير من التعثر في من الافلات سنه الفين
وعشره الى اثنين دول
المرشح ثم الرئيس الامريكي كذلك مع الشركه
بضروره امداد المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالطاقه النوويه الذي مساله الامن القومي
للولايات المتحده سيئه من القومي للولايات
المتحده
هددوا العرض المساله على النحو التالي
اولا بالاضافه الى الفوائد الجمه جدا
السوق الامريكي والشركات الامريكيه
وبالاضافه الى كانت بقى قادر على تنفيذ
وعد انتخابي وتكسب شريحه ضخمه جدا من ال
العاملين في هذه الشركات ومن رؤساء
الشركات اللي هي دعمت في الانتخابات
القادمه انت كمان قادر على اه اه اعاده
الامن منطقه الشرق الاوسط اللي كان هو اذا
انت رفات وتمسكت بالضوابط الامريكيه سوف
تسعى السعوديه وغيرها من دول المنطقه
لمباراه ايران في الحصول على التكنولوجيا
النوويه
والتكنولوجيا النووي اذا احنا قدمناها
تقدمها الروس هي الدينيين ممكن تقدمها
كوريا الشماليه ممكن تقدمها باكستان
تقدمها اي دوله اخرى بس الفرق
اذا احنا قدمناها سنكون قادرين على مراقبه
ما يجري وضبط والتاكد ان هذه التكنولوجيا
لن تتحول اه سرا اه من تكنولوجيا سلميه
الى التكنولوجيا النوويه وعملوا المقترحات
دي من خلال ثلاثه تقارير الثلاثه حمل
عنوان
اه الكل انفرد ليست خطه مرحليه للقرن
الواحد وعشرين للشرق الاوسط وكلمه مارس
لبنان يعني قياسا على خطه مرشد اللي
عملتها الولايات المتحده بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لاعاده بناء اوروبا هكذا
بس الاسمده مش اسم يعني اه اسم لازم نتوقف
عنده
وقت لاحق
خلاص الان انه بموجبه يجب ان نمد السعوديه
تكنولوجيا وبدؤوا في الاجراءات واتباعا
مستمره وزي ما كشف التقارير ان الغايه 12
فبراير الجاري كانت شركه اي بي ثري مجتمع
مع الرئيس الامريكي عشان تناقش صفقه
السعوديه ضمن امور اخرى طبعا الامور دي
بالنسبه للكونغرس امور مرفوضه الى عده
اعتبارات رقم واحد
بيع تكنولوجيا النوويه
للسعوديه امرنا عليه امر مرفوض ل عده امور
اولا السعوديه تجارب رغبتها في اقتناء
سلاح نووي التكنولوجيا النوويه
تكنولوجيا عسكريه نوويه اثنين انه هذه
الدوله منذ ان تم الكشف عن مقتل جمال
خاشقجي واتهام ولي العهد بالضلوع في
المساله وهما شنوا حمله شديده جدا على
السعوديه و مقاطعتها حتى على مستويات دنيا
يعني في المعاملات البسيطه فما بالنا احنا
بنتكلم على امدادها ب سلاح نووي هكذا يقول
المعارضين للفكره الامر الثالث انه ان
السعوديه مش بس بتعلن فيها تنتهي رفض
التوقيع على التخلي شرط او المشرط ال اللي
بيسموه الشرطه الذهبي في التخلي عن حقها
في تخصيب اليورانيوم وبالتالي هي عندها
النيه مبيته الامر الرابع ان
الاسماء اللي تورطت في في عمليه الوساطه
او اقناع الضغط على الرئيس الامريكي بيع
التكنولوجيا هي اسماء يعني تحت الشبهه تحت
مستوى الشبهات يعني مثلا مايكل فلندا اللي
هو جنرال امريكي سابق
والتقاعد عمل شركه سنه 2014 على التصدي كل
الجهات يعني على اتصال مثلا بالروس هو
بيتحكم دلوقتي يسلطوا بالروس علاقات
مشبوهه
بالمخابرات الروسيه كما كان متعاقد مع
الحكومه التركيه عشان يعملها عمليه ما بين
دول الدفاع المصالحه و متهم بانه كان
بيمثل عمليه اختطاف
اولا انه هو رجل الدين او الخص من الراي
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وتعاقد مع
الحكومه التركيه في 2016
الاخطر من كده انه كمان رغم انه هو كان في
تضر بمصالح وكان مستشار الامن القومي ومع
ذلك هو بيعمل عمليه التنسيق لمصالح عدد
كبير جدا من الشركات اللي عاوزه تستفيد من
اه
صفقه ضخم جدا مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مائه مليار من السعوديه وحدها على مدار
خمسه وعشرين سنه فما بالك لاسواق حتى هنا
ادي الهدف السعودي
موقف الرئيس الامريكي اللي هو كان بيت
عنها سرا لانه هو شايف ان ده ها يفيد وهو
على المستوى الشخصي يفيد الشركات ها يفيد
السوق الامريكي هو مقتنع انه يقطع الطريق
على منافسين اخرين اي الاعتبارات الاخرى
ما كانتش مهمه اوي ان نسعى
لتحقيقها يسفر عن ايه احنا محتاجين ننتظر
الايام القليله القادمه لكن بينما احنا
بدنا ننتظر الواضح جدا ان السعوديه تسعى
وتسعى بجديه للحصول على سلاح نووي ماذا
قدرتها على النجاح يتوقف على امور كثيره
كان كان فيه قصه
اه منتشره يعني زمان انه اه زعيم عربي راح
لي ماو تسي تونغ الزعيم الصيني وقال لي
احنا عايزين نشر القنبله النوويه فرض عليه
ان القنبله النوويه لا تشتري ولكن تصنع
ودي كانت مثل قصه كانت حقيقيه او كان
حقيقيه في ابو القنبله النوويه ليش مثلا
اه صفق الطيران والدبابات ولا اه اجهزه
حاسب الي انتي مساله خطيره جدا لا يمكن
شراء لكن الواضح ان الامور تغيرت
وان مع التغير الظروف ومع الضغوط
الاقتصاديه الشديده اصبحت فكره شراء
السلاح النووي او التكنولوجيا النوويه
القائمه رغم كل
المحاولات تستفيد طيارين في امريكا تيار
مطمئن تماما
انه
السعوديه لن تمثل اي خطر للسنين بال عشرات
السنين حتى لو تحتلها التكنولوجيا النوويه
والسبب انه بيقولوا انه زي دوله زي ما
فريد زكريا كان بيقول دوله من صنع سياره
يبقى ازاى انا
صنع صنع قنبله نوويه بلدي عاوزه قاعده
علميه ضخمه جدا غير متوفره بالسعوديه
وفي اطار الثاني يمكن ا اشرنا لو قبل كده
في حاله اسمها القنبله النوويه العربيه
يقول حضروا انتو مستخفين بالمساله
السعوديه ما عندهاش قاده المائه كبيره بس
لحظه انه باكستان ما كانتش عندها قاطع
المائه عظيمه جدا افضل اللي موجوده في
السعوديه ولكن بالنهايه هي تمكنت قاعده
علميه مع اولى محدوده بانها تطور قنبله
نوويه ما بتصنع السيارات ومازالت حتى الان
لا تصنع للسيارات ولا غير سيارات يكون انه
الدوله ما عندهاش قاعده علميه كبيره لا
يمنعها اذا توفرت طموح والمال والاصرار
والقدره على مجابهه
الضغوط الدوليه ممكن في تطور
تكنولوجيا عسكريه نوويه ايه اللي تعمل
السعوديه
علينا ان ننتظر ونرى اشكركم والى لقاء اخر
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]